we've all heard of mind over matter but
is it possible that the right motivation
can actually help repair spinal damage
I've come to Lausanne Switzerland to
find out about some innovative research
being done to repair the spinal cords of
rats using pharmaceuticals electrical
signals and the key ingredient
motivation sometimes with the right
motivation anything is possible
[Music]
Libya the main function of the spinal
cord is to transmit neural signals or
messages between the brain and the rest
of the bodies so when the spinal cord is
severed or crushed these messages can't
get past the injury the result is often
chronic paralysis research in this area
generally focuses on regenerating
damaged nerve fibers but here in
Lausanne they're taking a different
approach they come in the land Thank You
professor cortines work with rats is
producing remarkable results so I
thought what can we actually deliver to
the spinal cord the kind of information
that the brain would deliver naturally
in order to work the rats have their
spinal cords cut in two places although
not completely severed signals can't get
past the lesion leaving the rats
paralyzed to reactivate the healthy but
disconnected neural cells below the
injury the researchers administer a
cocktail of synthetic neurotransmitters
followed by electrical stimulation
that connects to the electrodes on the
spinal cord so we can provide the
stimulation to the spinal cord okay
so there are cables that run down the
spinal cord it actually runs under the
skin and then it's sutured on top of the
spinal cord this electrochemical
combination mimics the input of the
brain and reawakens the spinal cord
below the lesion no I start the trend me
immediately start working it's amazing
right the result after a few weeks of
training and while on the treadmill the
rat is incredibly able to walk again
so this animal was completely paralyzed
five minutes ago and now she's suing
continue stepping on the treadmill and I
will go training speed immediately the
animal is capable of like litter is
printing on the treadmill I look at this
you cannot even do it yourself I will
stop the treadmill up she stands but
this is happening without the
involvement of the brain at this stage
the rats stepping is stimulated by the
treadmill the legs are moving
independently of the brain so the
movement is completely involuntary you
can trend rats on this treadmill for
tomorrow you would not see recovery of
what I control why the brain is not
involved there is no motivation to walk
because you see the motivation is the
key to restoring voluntary movement so
this is where the irresistible Swiss
chocolate comes in
I brought a chocolate eclair I had half
but the other half is for the rat Yesi
she does like that's it we have a
combination of like actually yogurt and
chocolates which is a rat love this
reward-based training without a
treadmill was the focus of the next
phase of research they designed a
special robot which only supports the
paralyzed rat but doesn't propel it
forward this mean that the rats really
need to generate the propulsive forces
to go to well that we world which is a
circulates
so the rat is asked to go
yourself forward but she does get a
little bit of help up and down sir rats
have again been given electrochemical
stimulants but without the treadmill the
rat has to decide for itself if it wants
to walk when you want the animal to
participate they actively I mean we're
talking about the championships
rehabilitation you know you need to
motivate the right at any cost so rubia
does whatever it takes to coax the rat
to walk the rat is now walking when it
wants to which means the brain signals
are getting through to the previously
paralyzed limbs she's done really well
yeah the rat spinal cord seems much more
capable of rewiring itself than anyone
expected in one of the most extensive
examples observed it's been able to
detour around the injury and reconnect
the dormant neural network but what we
observe is that the cat fibres basically
they grow and deliver to this known and
elusive injury enough information we
don't know what kind but sufficient
information from the brain to other
voluntary control what we're hearing is
evidence of the rat making the decision
to walk the popping sound is a neuron
firing and here she's just standing but
you'll see once she starts walking
there's a pretty clear pattern of the
activity of the neuron with the rat
stepping it's showing that the movement
is voluntary that's that's really cool
that was really exciting the first time
that happened because you know we had
this idea that the brain should be
involved but it hadn't been proven
there's a whole team of people working
and everybody's pushing the rat and
everybody's all go-go-go and I could
hear it before it happened and I really
knew okay it's gonna work this time
with half of all human spinal injuries
leading to chronic paralysis professor
Cortines research gives new hope to
those affected so of course the next
obvious and no exciting goal is to try
this type of intervention human you know
it's difficult to say what this will
achieve in humans but you know it's very
promising new paths
[Music]